what do you want me to do can you be any
more amazing china anne mcclain we can't
get over your performance in black
lighten your the Jennifer Pierce we all
deserved you have such a colorful
background when it comes to the arts you
can sing dance act and make us laugh
like it's no big deal you give lightning
so much strength and depth which is why
you're one of our favorite metahumans we
can't get enough of The CW's black
lightning this nail-biting series has
got us hooked so we were super stunned
to find out that a huge Network dropped
the series before ever airing the pilot
we've got 10 fun facts about Black
Lightning coming your way so don't go
anywhere the GAM be astray if you
thought the name gambi sounded familiar
you weren't wrong it's a name that's
popped up more than a few times in the
CW's arrow verse in Black Lightning
gambie serves as the primary father
figure to the fantastical Jefferson
Pierce but he's so much more than that
he's not gonna hurt any more kids
he's Jefferson's weapons and armor
designer and black lightnings number one
Supporter but did you know that gambizzi
andre van appeared in the pilot episode
of the flash that's right Barry crashes
right into the back of a Gambia cleaners
van while attempting to get a grip on
his newfound powers Black Lightning
doesn't belong to the arrowverse you
would think that Black Lightning was a
part of the arrow verse but that isn't
exactly the case the CW's arrow verse
consists of the flash Batwoman arrow
legend of tomorrow and Supergirl Black
Lightning might appear to occur within
the arrow verse but showrunners Salem
aquiline Mara Brock Akhil have confirmed
that Black Lightning does not take place
in the same universe crisis on Infinite
Earths as it turns out Black Lightning
will be accounted for and one of the
biggest arrowverse crossovers ever
crisis on Infinite Earths is the sixth
annual shared multiverse crossover and
it's all set to air on December 8th 2019
the crossover takes place over the
course of five episodes which are said
to come to an end on January 14 2020 how
exciting is that
Kress williams recently revealed the
news and fans are super excited
Batman would be proud Bruce Wayne has a
strict no kill rule and it looks like
Jefferson Pierce follows the same path
as his mentor despite being a hero who
takes on extremely dangerous foes black
lightnings hands are clean he is one of
the few heroes who has never ended a
life but that isn't to say that Black
Lightning hasn't come close to breaking
his number-one rule if it wasn't for his
ability to control his voltage many of
his enemies would have kicked the bucket
by now african-american roots have you
ever wondered who the genius behind
Black Lightning is well you wouldn't be
the first although little known Black
Lightning was the first black comic book
hero to have been created by an
african-american artist Trevor von Eden
was only 17 years old when he came up
with the concept an artwork for the
electrifying Jefferson Pierce writer
Tony Isabella worked alongside Trevor to
create the comic book and well the rest
is pretty much history the gold medal
Olympian before Jefferson Pierce became
the crime-fighting principal we all know
and love he used to be a gold medal
winning Olympic decathlete Olympic
medalists are known for their extreme
dedication and perseverance which is why
it comes as no surprise that Black
Lightning has what it takes to take home
the gold after winning his title
Jefferson decided to move back to his
hometown of southside metropolis morning
gentlemen and that's where his real
story begins the Fox connection you can
catch the latest Black Lightning episode
on the CW but did you know that the TV
series was originally going to air on
Fox Black Lightning was first developed
at Fox and it would have aired on the
network in September of 2016 if Fox
hadn't something chosen to pass on the
series despite their pilot commitment
Fox wanted out
but within 24 hours the project was
taken on by the CW and given an official
pilot order the first of her kind
now FSO Williams is one of a kind for
more reasons than one the actress who
portrays and this appears opened up
about what makes her character so
special while on the set of Late Night
with Seth Meyers nafisa is honored to
play the first black female lesbian
superhero on TV
she loves how much diversity her
character brings to the show so super
honored to you know be that voice and we
couldn't agree with her more Green
Lanterns sister here's something that
just may surprise you Lynne Pierce is
connected to another member of DC's
justice league Lynn's maiden name is
Lynne Stewart and she said to be Jon
Stewart's sister commonly known as the
Green Lantern of Earth but Lynne isn't
one to throw names around which is why
she tends to keep her main name to
herself so I'm gonna need you to change
the way you talk to me
black lightnings powers Black Lightning
isn't your average hero and unlike
Superman he doesn't have a kryptonite
he's one of the few DC heroes who
doesn't have any weaknesses which makes
him all the more amazing but don't be
fooled with black lightnings only
weakness is his heart he loves his
family and his students and would do
anything for them which could be used
against him in the long run who is your
favorite character from Black Lightning
and why sound off in the comments and
that's a wrap subscribe to the things
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching we'll
catch you later
you